- He's a Russian chess grandmaster
and former chess world champion.
He's considered by many to be
the greatest chess player of all time.
He became the youngest ever
undisputed World Chess Champion at age 22.
He's Garry Kasparov
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
(wind howling)
(basketball bouncing)
- It's very important, and
I also come back to chess,
to learn how to recognize your
own strengths and weaknesses.
This is in fact the
vital part of preparation
for a big match and for anything in life.
We always try to study our opponents.
We always try to study the battlefield.
We always try to study
all the circumstances
surrounding our venture or endeavor.
But, very often we
forget to study ourself,
and this is very important
because any choice
of a ground for a battle
or a type of strategy
you want to employ
depends on our recognition
of our strengths and weaknesses.
And this is a process
of constant reevaluation
because life is changing very fast
and our opponents, looking at our success,
studying it, and trying to be smart
and outsmart us eventually.
And we can look at the
history and just to find
a number of situations where the inability
to recognize strengths and weaknesses
lead to an eventual disaster.
(taps chess clock)
(piece hits table)
It's up to us, what we want
to do with our success,
because, you know, eventually
if we are successful
we just have to make a
conscious decision what's next.
And for me, there was
always a next station
because it wasn't enough
for me just to win.
I always wanted to make a difference.
It could also remind us of
success of Alexander Bell,
the inventor of telephone,
who had a stack of notebooks
where he recorded every failed experiment.
So if you work really hard
you can find the winning spot
even in the midst of
your numerous failures.
I think the ex-speaker of
US House of Representatives
Newt Gingrich hit the right
points when he said that
perseverance is hard work you do
after you get tired of doing
hard work you already did.
I think that, again, from my perspective,
patience is your ability
to also accept failures
because very often today,
even from kindergarten,
and of course in schools,
and of course in colleges,
and of course at the work
place in businesses we hear,
oh, failure, failure.
You know, failure's nothing but failure.
Well, failure is inevitable
step toward success.
If you don't take a risk, how
can you be sure about rewards?
Especially if you're
looking for something big.
You want to do something
that never happened before.
You're looking for breaks or innovations.
It's like sort of the Moon project.
Something that is for the blue skies.
It means you have to
enter uncharted waters,
sort of untested territories.
And again, for me, patience is also
a willingness to accept failure,
defeat, and to try again.
I learned that, you know,
it's never late to learn.
So that's why even at age 37
you can learn from a younger generation
and that was a very important lesson
not only for the remaining
five years of my chess career,
but also for future years,
because I just recognized that,
I mean, flexibility is a
fundamental quality for success.
We should learn how to
trust our gut, intuition.
Because in most of the
stories I looked at,
and in most of the quotes I collected
I didn't see people picking up intuition
as the crucial element of the success.
While, in my profession in chess,
intuition is virtually everything.
Because chess, some
people don't recognize it,
is a mathematically infinite game.
The number of moves in the
game of chess, all the moves
contains 120 zeroes, which is
more than number of seconds
since the moment Big
Bang created universe.
So, how can you find your way, you know,
in this ocean of possibilities?
And of course, how a
man can fight a machine
that could calculate
10s and 10s of millions
of positions per second?
Intuition, because it's all
about decision making process
and we never employ
calculation as the main tool.
It's one percent of
calculation, even less,
and 99% of our
understanding of our ability
to find intuitive ways
to compare incompatible,
material verses qualitative,
time verses material.
So intuition plays a key
role and we have to trust
our intuition, our instincts,
because in life also
we have many opportunities where
we cannot foresee all the consequences
and there's only one choice,
is just to trust your gut.
Because when we win, we forget
that there are a lot of
people who are losing
and those who are losing
they are analyzing.
They're trying to find out
the reasons for their loss,
the mistakes, and if we do nothing,
if we rest on our laurels,
they'll come back after us next time.
And I was on top of the
world just for 20 years
because I was very good, even relentless
in challenging my own success.
- [Interviewer] And did
you go over all your games?
- Absolutely
- [Interviewer] The ones you succeeded
and the ones you failed?
- Absolutely, yeah.
Because even the game we won
always contained mistakes,
inaccuracies, it's inevitable.
And I can hardly imagine one
Berlin game with no mistakes,
which means that you won--
- [Interviewer] On both sides?
- Yeah, on both sides.
- [Interviewer] But the trick is noticing
when the other guy makes a mistake.
- Absolutely, yeah.
If we won, it's most
likely because our opponent
made their last mistake,
but he made the last mistake
and he's definitely analyzing the game
and he'll find what we did wrong
in the previous stage of the game,
so what is important is to find it first
and to make sure that next time
when he's trying to actually
surprise us with something
we'll be one step ahead.
I made the conscious
decision that Linares 2005
will be my last professional
and today I played my
last professional game.
- Is there a maximum age, or
can you be a chess champion
if you want to be at 65?
- It's a very demanding game,
so you have to spend time at the computer
analyzing, preparing new ideas
and then you just play
under this heavy pressure,
so it sucks a lot of energy out of you
and players in their 20s or
early 30s, they definitely
have a physical advantage
over older competitors.
I probably would be able
to play a few more years,
but I made a decision to retire
and it was not just overnight, you know,
at the end of the tournament in Spain
in the city of Linares, but
just beforehand I thought
I already made enough
difference in the game of chess.
So just making a difference was important,
and I just recognized that
maybe it's time just to move on.
Just to start changing my
life before it's too late.
You can't stay in chess indefinitely,
because everybody needs challenges
and I thought about other challenges.
Is there any universal recipe for success?
I don't think so.
I think we're all unique
and it all depends on us,
what kind of ingredients, and
they're similar ingredients,
we'd like to put into
our own magic formula.
When we look at the
examples from the history,
look at the success stories.
We could find a different
definition of success.
For instance, Mikhail Botvinnik,
the sixth world champion
known for his notoriety
and called the patriarch
of the Soviet chess school.
Probably the greatest scientist
in the history of chess.
So, his formula was very solid,
and very much the ground.
Talent, good health, strong
nerves, fighting spirit,
and good work ethic, it worked.
Thomas Edison was even duller.
He said success is 1% inspiration
and 99% of perspiration.
But just look at the
different side of equation.
Alexander Pushkin, the
greatest Russian poet,
considered to be the father of
the modern Russian language.
It's the man who with the
lightest touch of genius
could produce the best pieces
of Russian literature ever.
He was a man of joy, he was a gambler.
He was even a rake, always
lived in the red ink.
So his formula is quite different.
A genius, luck, and
experience, it also worked.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
one of you asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also to love which of
Garry Kasparov's top ten rules
meant the most to you, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(wind rushing)
(basketball bouncing)